[Music]
thank you
that one and I was already I left my
family behind including my wife and
children I left them in the fighting
there was no Force to protect civilians
the rapid support forces attacked us
from every side even in streets when we
tried to flee
they didn't leave people alive they
attacked people and the dead were left
on the streets
foreign
[Music]
forces Fighters and militias aligned
with them going door to door asking
people about their ethnicity executing
entire families based on their
identification as muscle
[Music]
thank you
if this off-repeated phrase of never
again is to mean anything
it must mean something here and now
for the people of Darfur that have lived
with this uncertainty and pain and the
scars of conflict
for almost two decades
[Music]